STUDENT: So my
perspectives about language
have changed significantly
over the course of this class.
I think in awakening
me and making
me acknowledge biases and
perceptions that I had
and trying to recognize that
all languages are equal.
You know, and thinking about
other aspects of my life
where, you know, wanting as
a minority woman of color,
thinking of equality
in that terms
that I never thought to
apply it to language.
I never really considered
how important language
is as far as identity.
You know, we learned a lot
about how, in this class,
language is not just--
there are political, social,
and economic implications.
And so, I feel like this class
has changed my perspective
in making me aware
of those things
and realizing that language
is important and that, yeah,
that all languages are equal.